in regard to lou lou elizondo's remote
viewing talents has lou or anyone else
on the team of bass used their remote
viewing capabilities to
see into installations of
that purportedly house crafts bodies or
to communicate with slash locate uaps
and then they even wrote in bracket this
ties into page 120 on remote viewing
well i'm glad
they have
spent so much time uh annotating the
pages because frankly i don't know what
page 120 says but
um
in terms of remote viewing um
bigelow aerospace advanced space studies
proposed a remote viewing project to
defense intelligence agency as part of
the menu or proposals that we submitted
in response to the request for proposals
that dia put out
dia actually rejected that proposal uh
they said we don't want to spend
enormous amounts of money train training
remote viewers but they did allow us to
conduct a pilot program
on the uh on remote viewing and in the
book at um we we did a contract with
uh legendary remote viewer joe mike
monaco who um we you know
per the usual method for remote viewing
we gave him only
latitude and long longitude coordinates
and
he he produced a report for
the defense intelligence agency
ultimately but bass and
in it he mapped out the property and he
talked about various beings on the
property
in terms of a full-fledged
remote viewing exercise
we were not permitted under the
contract that we were uh given to
do a full remote viewing of the uh you
know during the bas program so we were
not permitted to do that by the defense
intelligence agency
george you have anything to add to that
yeah i'd add this is that uh column and
i wrote an earlier book called hunt for
the skinwalker which was
mainly focused on nids which is the
national institute for discovery science
pardon all the acronyms but nids was an
organization created by mr bigelow prior
to him getting a contract for the dia to
run this other program and needs studied
among other things skinwalker ranch in
in utah and just as sort of an
experiment
as a side note while preparing that book
i had tasked a remote viewing group here
in nevada to take a look at the ranch
without telling them what i was asking
them to look at they found some
interesting things they found evidence
of military surveillance they found some
indications of underground facilities
and control rooms so they were able to
pierce the veil of of a sort but of
course i was never able to physically
verify what they saw in these reviewing
visions was actually physically there
yeah it would be a really interesting
task and an endeavor to try to get
remote viewers to take a look at not
just the ranch but other places like
area 51 or places where we suspect
recovered discs for medical medic metal
pieces bits and pieces from crash sites
might be stashed we haven't done it